you you do the book as PJ next or is
there something in between
a meeting like when we met yeah
um yeah so we met
he he actually came to my hosting
um in 2018 May of 2018 so that's like
basically where we first met it was not
romantic like I literally had a job
there he's like hey I'm gonna come by
okay cool
um
he invited me to his his game at UK
February 2019.
right so we met
um I went back for my birthday so I went
to two Kentucky games and that's when we
first started talking like after my
birthday we talked almost every single
day and I was aware like he's younger
than me I always had a lot of judgment
towards guys who were younger than me
because I'm like you're younger than me
how can you handle me you know right
um but I always felt like PJ saw me for
me
and that is the [ __ ] god to honest
truth
um
it makes me sad even thinking about it
because like
I don't know you just think people get
you and it just doesn't work out so
that's why I overlooked some of those
things like the age oh he's about to be
in the NBA I overlooked that because I
felt like oh my God I finally have a guy
who doesn't judge me who sees me for me
and like accepts it and understands my
value so I felt like he was somebody
that like deserved all my time and
attention and
you know it just didn't end up working
out long term so and how old was he when
it started how old were you because this
is the the next 20. I've got a million
questions about the age thing I'm so
glad you brought it out you grooming
like they they said because I'm a
pedophile Predator what what just to
give context to the viewers at home if
you guys don't know anything about
Brittany I saw a video of you where you
were in the car saying this is basically
how to you can kind of get a kid off of
an NBA player and it's really easy
because these guys don't wear condoms
and it's something to that effect so
then a couple years later when you you
have a kid off an NBA player it looks
it's not a good look and especially that
he's a lot younger than you so what what
did you feel like was misrepresented
there
so to give a little bit more context to
the video too
um especially I think I made this video
in 2018 and I was in my car ranting you
know like I always do and people were
saying that you know you're a gold
digger you're this and you're that and
my way to defend myself this is what was
that one you also said that you pay for
your own flights too I was just I'm
trying to I I would have to go to my
archive and play the video in its
entirety to be able to confirm that okay
because there were other times I talked
about paying for my flights
um but in that video I was saying that
if I really was a gold digger
I could have several kids by now and so
it was an attempt to make a group of
people look bad and I made myself look
even worse because I'm like what are you
guys talking about I'm a gold digger
these athletes don't use condoms I could
have a baby by then right it aged
horribly right and I don't and I don't
ever try to deny that and I don't do
apology tours it is what it is I said
what I said like that was my truth that
was my experience the people that I was
encountering it's not even like an
athlete thing a lot of guys don't wear
condoms but it was surprising to me that
people of such high status were a little
bit more Reckless right
um and because we think they have so
much to lose yeah I guess that's exactly
what it is right it's like why would you
why do you trust me right and then as a
young person and you're not even young
person because so in your head you were
saying like [ __ ] the haters I could have
a kid that none of these people if you
wanted to catch a kid by an NBA player
it's really easy because they're dumb
right so that's where that the context
of that video right and then I met PJ
like we started talking when he was 20
years years old we have a six year age
Gap okay so you're 26. yeah 20. I'm
thinking I'm 26 I'm thinking
20 year olds are pretty immature but I'm
telling you when I met him I just felt
like and like genuinely yeah he had an
old soul that's how I felt about him so
a lot of people tried to
like
I don't know I feel like they tried to
tell me how I felt and like my
intentions and it's like I know the
truth like I know the person that I was
sitting across from at BJ's when we had
our first date in Kentucky and Lexington
like you can't you can't tell me that
you know I personally think 20 is old
enough to make your own decisions I put
myself when I was 20 and I'm thinking
you can't really be groomed at 20 years
old but for some reason I feel like back
then they said that you something about
you met him in high school I did not
even know he existed okay I didn't like
and honestly did you see him play in
high school never okay I don't but
that's what I'm saying the 200 000 a
month the meeting him when he was in
high school again like even when I first
was like I met PJ when I went to
Kentucky
um I was talking to someone who played
on the nuggets at the time and it was
something that I kind of had a history
with and when I met PJ and we had that
connection I immediately cut the guy
from the Nuggets off you see what I'm
saying so like I have [ __ ] going I did
not know he existed when he was in
[ __ ] high school what I'm pulling
Heavy Hitters what am I worried about a
[ __ ] kid in high school for but
that's where people just make up their
own [ __ ] so it's like well I can't
really
you guys are gonna say what the [ __ ] you
want to say all I can do is sit here and
tell you the truth you know so so 20 you
guys start talking when when did you get
pregnant
he I got pregnant and you were with him
for how long
um were you guys dating or were you like
linking no we were we were exclusive
when I got pregnant um so we talked from
February 2019 to February 2020. now
I don't know what he was doing with who
he was doing it with whatever
um but we started dating February 2020.
I left California
April of 2020 and I moved in with him
um I had my own place where I was
staying in his apartment we were
basically kind of living together
already he asked me to move in with him
in the summertime I got pregnant August
2020. so we had been a year and a half
at least familiar with one another but
exclusive probably those six eight
months six to eight months yeah and did
you say it was the child planned yeah I
mean my son is Paul Jermaine Washington
III okay like he has his father's name
sat down and said I want to have a yes
and I was on birth control for 10 years
because I never wanted to
go through an abortion that was just me
personally I'm like well if I can
prevent it and I'd rather be safe and
again like I'm hot I'm hopping I got
[ __ ] going on I'm definitely not trying
to have anybody's child right so I got
off birth control and there was a
conversation got off birth control I got
pregnant so it wasn't some oops I came
in you and you got pregnant like no it
was I want a family I want a child we're
gonna get married has PJ ever done like
interviews on this not at all no I'm
just curious would he say the same thing
yeah okay I mean the truth is the truth
you know I mean there's some things like
yeah we can share perspective right but
the facts of the matter are he was
planned so that can't that he can't even
be disputed you know um I always thought
PJ was like kind of quiet and more to
himself so I don't actually see him ever
really doing an interview like I feel
like now he's when we broke up how
everything panned out was like very
public and out of character from what I
knew of him
um but I don't foresee him doing an
interview I don't
okay so you guys you guys break up or no
you're together
um tell me how how did you guys split up
and you you can be as detailed or not
detailed as you want you don't have to
go into okay
um
there were some things like so I had
never gone through anybody's bone in
like my because at the time I was 28
right um girl you were dealing with
athletes I never went to anybody's phone
never except PJs okay okay yep because I
felt like if I have to go through your
phone yeah I already have my answer
right and I'm not doing that I'm not
playing [ __ ] detective right so I
went through his phone again this was
the summer like you know a few months
before I got pregnant found some stuff
in his phone I didn't like nothing
confirmed I mean you're just
entertaining [ __ ] like okay
I had never been cheated on that I knew
of right and I found out stuff that like
he had sex with someone in the beginning
of our relationship but this is in March
you slept with this girl I found out
July
I didn't already move my whole life
I'm already here
okay well you know you moved from L.A
yeah because I moved from Woodland Hills
I had a condo at Woodland Hills and I
moved all of my all my whole life to
Charlotte North Carolina to be with him
right
so I found out some stuff I'm like okay
you [ __ ] this girl in March all right
I love you and I know what you've seen
growing up
I've never forgiven anyone because I've
never caught anyone cheating on me but
like I understand your family Dynamics
so I can
I choose to understand and to forgive
you and so
one of my best friends
when we were talking about how we were
like basically trying to get pregnant
she was like do you think it's a good
idea because you just found out all this
stuff right like the voice of reason
right and she's like I don't think
that's a good foundation and I was just
like no I trust who I'm with like I get
it like we've talked about it I
understand and he is younger than me
right he's younger than me
I I'm gonna try I'm gonna try this I'm
gonna I've never done this but I'm just
gonna try to overlook it and move on so
with that knowledge again this is where
I was taking accountability too
I saw behaviors I saw red flags and I
still chose to move forward and it's
because I loved him I don't know I just
I believed in him and I guess that's
where I'm a foolish woman because I just
chose to believe in him yeah girls La La
Land respectfully yeah it's just like
and we talked about this a little bit
before I'm just thinking like an NBA
player faithful
I've seen him I I've said I've said this
before but I'm to the D3 level D3
D3 the nerve no
no we're on campus and it's like that's
division three basketball I'm thinking
division one has to be Madness then ba
has to be Madness yeah at first hand
you've been dealing with these guys for
like a decade you know it's Madness it
is and that's just where I kind of just
take it on the chin and I'm like I
believed in someone and it just didn't
work out and I know and he knows the
conversations in the cons in the
consistency that I thought you know like
this is more than enough for me to trust
it
um
I just believed in him and I again I can
accept my responsibility in that for
overlooking certain things that really
should have I should have as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible